The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Well, we're back.
And today we will
consider solutions
to harmonic oscillators with
damped harmonic oscillators.
And what I thought
would be best, in order
to focus on the new part,
the question of damping--
what effect it has on
the motion of harmonic
oscillators-- I decided I'll
take an oscillator, which
is one of those we
considered last time,
I could've taken
any one of them,
and add to it a drag force.
So let me discuss what
we're going to consider.
Suppose we have a rod,
the uniform rod of mass m
suspended from the pivot here.
This is the vertical plane.
So imagine a ruler, for
example, with a nail
through the end of
it can oscillate
in the plane of this board.
So we at a gain considering
rotations in two dimensions.
We will consider
rotations, which
are anti-clockwise, like
this, to have a positive sign.
And if it's clockwise,
that's a negative rotation.
This particular mass rod
we assume has a mass m.
It's uniform length l.
And initially, it's just
suspended like this.
So at time equals 0.
This is the position,
and at that instant,
we hit the bottom.
There's an impulse acting on it.
And that impulse instantaneously
gives an angular velocity
to this rod, which is of
course the rate of change
of the angle.
And we assume it
has some number.
And so that it's easy for you
to remember what that number is,
I'm calling it the angular
velocity at t equals 0.
But remember, this is simply
the initial angular velocity
that this rod has.
At any instant of
time later, this rod
will be at some other angle.
I've shown here, theta of t.
This is at time t.
And it may be
moving at that time.
And the angular velocity in this
direction we call theta dot t.
These are anti-clockwise
rotations.
And so these are positive.
This is as that angle.
And if this is a
positive number,
this is rotating
in that direction.
So this is the same
simple harmonic oscillator
we considered last time.
And what I now want to
take a slightly more
realistic situation.
All harmonic oscillators
in the universe
have some drag,
maybe very small,
some mechanism by which
they lose kinetic energy.
So we were going to assume
that this oscillator has
some drag torque applied to it.
It could be friction around
the pivot, it could be the air,
this could be inside
the liquid, you name it.
Now, I am going to
make the assumption
that the presence of
the damping mechanism
exerts a drag
torque on this rod.
And I'm going to make the
assumption that the drag
force is proportional
to the angular velocity.
Since the drag force is
in the opposite direction
to the angular
velocity obviously,
there is a minus
sign here and this
is the constant of
proportionality.
Now, you may well ask why did
I assume this is the case?
Is that because in nature
it's normally like that?
No.
The reason why I chose
this form is very simple.
I know from experience that
if I use this drag force,
I can analytically
solve my equations.
If I take a more realistic
version of the force,
then the final solutions
I'm going to get it
are not analytically soluble.
It doesn't mean you
can't solve them.
You can solve them
by a computer.
But for teaching you
how to solve problems,
it's not going to be
very helpful if I then
say go into a computer
and get the computer
to solve it for you.
So the choice of
this resistive force
which is proportional to the
rate of change of position
of the rod is chosen
for that reason.
The other thing I will do, once
again-- because of what you
saw last time that
happened-- assume
that the displacement
of this rod is small.
We're only going to
consider small oscillations.
In other words,
we'll only assume
it's sufficiently small so
that we can approximate sine
of the angle by
the angle itself.
Again, the reason why we do
that is so that at the end,
we'll be able to solve
the equations of motion.
Now, if you ask
yourself, hold on.
We're doing all
these approximations.
Does this correspond to reality?
And the answer is the following.
In problems that we are
doing on the board like this,
we're taking
idealized situations.
For those idealized
situations, the prediction
of what will happen is exact.
But since the description
of the situations
is it not exactly equal
to what you'd normally
have in the world, the
answers that we get
are only as accurate to the
degree of the assumptions.
But certainly from
solutions like this,
we can get a sense
in understanding
what happens, because
for example, the drag
force slightly different
will not qualitatively
change what the actual
motion is, et cetera.
And this happens throughout
so-called problem solving
land in any physics
that you consider.
So this is the physical
description of the situation.
And what we want
to do, as before,
find out what this rod
will do qualitatively
as a function of
time and also be
able to predict
exactly where it will
be at the given instant of time.
So that's what I mean by I'm
going to solve this problem.
Now, I chose the
same oscillator as I
say so that you don't have to
focus so much on the rising
equation of motion, but more
on what the frictional torque
does, how that changes
what we learned before.
So here is the free body
diagrams or the force
diagram, which
corresponds to this.
Here is the pivot.
This represents the rod.
What forces act on this rod?
Well, there's going to
be the force of gravity.
And you know from the
studies of rigid body motion
that we can understand what
torque this force exerts
by considering that
the force of gravity
acts at the center
of mass of this rod.
So if you take the
center of mass,
this location, then
there'll be a force
of gravity on this mass.
The mass of the rod
will be m, so there'll
be an mg force acting
downwards there.
This force applied to this
rigid body will exert a torque.
In this case, it'll be a
clockwise and negative torque.
In addition to
that, there will be
a torque acting on this due
to the frictional force.
And that, we said, we
will call b theta dot.
So what is the equation
of motion for this rod?
The acceleration of the
angular acceleration
of this rod from tau
is equal to i alpha.
The acceleration will be
equal to the torque divided
by the moment of inertia.
Since this is rotations of a
rigid body in a plane in two
dimensions, I don't have to
write any vector quantities.
On writing the equations,
this is the component
of the rotations about an axis
perpendicular to the board
here.
So the angular
acceleration will be
equal to the total torque,
which is the torque due
to gravity plus the torque
due to the drag divided
by the moment of inertia.
And by the way, the
moment of inertia
of a rod like this about
one end is 1/3 ml squared.
So this is the torque
due to gravity on this.
It's minus because,
as I mentioned here,
it's a clockwise torque
minus b theta dot.
That's also minus that, because
the drag force is always
in opposition to the angular
velocity divided by i.
As we did last time for
the harmonic oscillator,
in order for me to write fewer
numbers or algebraic symbols
on the board, I define
some quantities.
I will define omega 0 squared
to be equal to 3 g over l.
I'll define gamma
to be b over I--
that constant
proportionality divided
by the inertia of this
system, the moment of inertia.
And I will, as I said, assume
that this angle's always
sufficiently small for the
accuracy with which one
I want to predict
what will happen,
I can assume that sine
delta t is equal to theta t.
Now let me be honest with you.
I defined these
quantities not only
to make my life easier
in writing things down,
but as you'll see as we go on,
it will serve a useful purpose
for comparing how all sorts
of harmonic oscillators
behave with or without
damping, et cetera.
If I take these definitions
and make this assumption
and I take this and play
around with the algebra,
I'll end up with this equation.
I end up with an equation
that theta double
dot, the second derivative
of theta and the angular
acceleration times gamma times
the angular velocity plus omega
0 squared times the angular
position is equal to 0.
This is the equation of
motion for this system.
And the other
thing which we know
that initially the
theta at 0 is 0
and the initial
angular velocity is
this number, angular
velocity at t equals 0.
These three equations
are absolutely,
from the point of
view of physics,
equivalent to the
description we had.
Here we had this
physical description
of somebody's--
this rod, et cetera.
These mathematical equations
describe this situation.
In order to predict what will
happen, what we now have to do
is solve these equations.
So that's what I will do now.
So I will solve this equation.
And let me remind you, as
I discussed in the past,
I cannot emphasize
it enough now.
I am not trying to
teach you mathematics.
I am trying to help you learn
how to solve physical systems,
how to predict how a
given physical system will
behave as a function of time.
So for me,
mathematics is a tool.
I need a solution
of that equation.
And this is a linear
second order differential
equation in time.
And I know from mathematics
that if I find an equation which
solves that and if it has
2 arbitrary constants--
in other words, the
solution satisfies
that equation for all values
of those arbitrary constants.
Then I have found the one and
only solution of that equation.
And so let me tell you.
I will solve this by using
this uniqueness theorem.
I know that that
equation, unfortunately,
is a little harder to
solve than the one we
did last time for
simple harmonic motion.
One finds that the
solution of that equation
actually depends
on these constants.
For the harmonic oscillator,
the type of equation,
which was the solution, did
not depend on those constants.
Here, it does.
One finds that if you
have gamma squared greater
than omega 0 squared--
in other words,
if you have this big constant
bigger than a certain amount,
this means you
have heavy damping.
You have one kind of a solution,
while if it's that other way
about, if this is
bigger than that,
you get a different
kind of a solution.
It's not obvious, but that's
what mathematics tells you.
So let me consider first
the case of strong damping.
B is big.
And so we're talking
about situation,
you have this oscillator.
But there's lots
of friction, so it
doesn't move smoothly at all.
This is greater than that.
Under those
conditions, you'll find
that this equation satisfies
our equation of motion.
Now actually, Professor
Walter Lewin, in his lectures,
did show you how you can prove
that this equation satisfies
our equation of motion for
these specific conditions.
He used complex amplitude.
And you can review his
lectures and you can see that.
Or you can look it up in books
on the solution of differential
equations.
For me, it is
adequate that I found
a solution which
satisfies this equation.
Now, note this is a
solution of that equation
where the alpha 1 and
alpha 2 are defined here.
It's all defined in
known quantities.
Gamma omega 0 are
known quantities
for any specific problem
in particular for the one
we're solving.
So here, every term is known.
The A and the B are the
2 arbitrary constants.
In other words, this equation
satisfies our equation
of motion for all
values of A and B.
So again, by the
uniqueness theorem,
this is the most general
solution to our problem
provided the damping
is very high.
If this is the theta
of t, then of course
the angular velocity theta dot
of t, just differentiate here.
And I get minus alpha 1 A
e to the minus alpha 1 t
and minus alpha 2 B
to the minus alpha t.
We want to find the solution
to our particular problem.
So we found it that
satisfies the equation
of motion for our system.
We now want to make sure
that we have a solution which
satisfies the
boundary conditions.
In other words, which
is consistent with what
we said this rod was
doing at t equals 0.
At t equals 0, we said the rod
was vertically, so theta of 0
is 0.
And we also said that
at that instance,
there was an impulse
given to the rod.
And so its angular velocity
at t equals 0 was this number,
the angular velocity
at t equal 0.
So we must now make sure that
the A and B, these arbitrary
constants, are consistent
with these initial conditions.
And it's obvious
how you do that.
You take this equation and
I take what is theta at t
equals 0.
Well, it's 0.
So that's 0 equals
to t equals 0.
This is one, so it's A, plus
when t equals 0, this is B.
So it's A plus B. So we know
that A must be equal to minus
B. That's to
satisfy the boundary
conditions that the rod
was vertical at t equals 0.
How about the other
boundary condition?
We know that t equals 0, the
angular velocity theta dot
is angular velocity
at t equals 0.
And so angular at t equals 0
must be equal to minus alpha 1
times A. And t
equals 0, this is 1.
So it's minus alpha 1 A. And
here, minus alpha 2 B. OK,
we now have 2 equations with 2
knowns, 2 algebraic equations.
Therefore, we can
find A and B. In fact,
we found already that A is equal
to minus B from this equation.
And then replacing
B by minus A, we
find that A is angular velocity
t equals 0 and alpha t over 1.
So what do we find?
We have found that the specific
solution to our equation
of motion which satisfies
these boundary conditions
is theta of t is equal A
e to the minus alpha 1 t.
A is angular velocity
at t equals 0 into e
to the minus alpha 1 t.
And B is minus A. So it's
minus e to the minus alpha 2t.
So we have solved that problem.
This equation
describes the motion
of this compound pendulum,
the rod, completely.
If you ask me for a
time, I will tell you
exactly the angle at which
this will be hanging.
There are no more
unknowns in this.
Furthermore, it gives me a
sense of what that rod is doing.
And actually, it's
a bit of a surprise.
We've considered
here an oscillator,
we'd expect an
oscillator to oscillate.
This equation doesn't oscillate.
It is the sum of 2
exponential functions.
If I just qualitatively
plot this,
if you compare
alpha 2 to alpha 1,
you find that alpha 2
is greater than alpha 1.
So this exponential
has a bigger exponent.
It will be dropping
faster than this one.
So what do we have?
This is my angular velocity.
Velocity at t equals 0.
Let's consider one of them.
This is 1.
It's an exponential function.
Here, I'm plotting the
angle as a function of time.
I'll get some exponential
function like this,
starting at that value.
And the other function's
also an exponential one,
which has a higher
value of the exponent.
And therefore, it'll
drop more quickly,
starts with the same
amplitude, so it'll
go more quickly like this.
The net motion is the
difference between those 2.
Take this one minus that one.
What does that look like?
Well, qualitative you
can see I start at 0.
Far out here, it'll be 0,
because the 2 exponentials
will approach 0.
So out here, and it'll
be 0 or approaching 0.
It'll be some magnitude in here.
And so I will get something
like this happening.
It's the difference of the
2 exponential functions.
Isn't it amazing?
Let's think for a second
what we have shown.
We've taken this
harmonic oscillator,
we've put it in a situation
with a lot of friction,
we gave it a kick,
and we described it
in terms of these
mathematical equations.
I then blindly
applied mathematics,
solved these equations,
and predicted
that this will be the motion.
No oscillations.
Let's stop now for a second.
By common sense, what
would you expect?
Imagine you had this
rod and something which
is very, very viscous--
very high drag.
You give it a kick, it will
move, because of inertia it
will move.
But it will get slowed down.
It will finally come to a halt.
And it'll slowly come back.
But if the resistive torque is
so big, it'll never overshoot.
So this is exactly
what you'd expect.
And as I say, it is amazing.
I always find it
amazing, because this
is a magnificent
example that mathematics
is the language that one can
use to describe the nature,
and that solving the
mathematical equations
predicts what will actually
happen in a given situation.
Enough philosophizing.
Let's now consider
the other possibility.
So I'll now do a
second problem where
I will have very weak damping.
So imagine a more
realistic situation.
We take our pendulum,
this compound pendulum,
and we include the
resistive torque
due to the air, for example,
that's there, et cetera.
Again, I am taking
the same pendulum
so that we just focus on
the effect of the damping.
So I think I have it here.
Everything up to here
will be exactly the same.
The only thing
we've now changed,
we've said that this little b is
big such that the gamma squared
is smaller, it doesn't
have to be much smaller,
so that gamma squared is
less than 4 omega squared.
In other words, B
is less than this.
So it's the weak damping case.
You may well ask, hold on.
Why look for any
other solutions?
I have found a solution
for this equation before.
And up there was the
two exponentials.
Why can't we just take
those and say look,
that equation satisfies this
equation, that value of theta,
and just repeat this?
Well, try it and you'll
see you immediately get
into difficulties.
In this formulation, you
see that alpha 1 and alpha 2
include a square root of gamma
squared minus 4 omega squared.
We had no problem with
that when gamma squared was
greater than 4 omega squared
and take the square root of it.
But if gamma squared is
less than 4 omega squared,
that square root is the
square root of a minus number.
And how is that going to
represent a physical situation?
So the method breaks down.
In other words,
for this case, we
had not found an
equation which satisfies
our equation of motion with
these boundary conditions.
So we've got to try again.
And there is an
equation that does.
And I've written it here.
One finds that
theta of t is equal
to some arbitrary
constant A e to the minus
gamma over 2t times cosine,
omega prime t plus phi
where omega prime is well
defined in terms of omega 0
and gamma is given here.
And there's no problem.
We have now gamma squared
is less than that,
so this is a real number.
So it's no problem with
that square root plus phi.
So we have 2
arbitrary constants.
Try it.
Take this equation,
differentiate it twice,
and calculate it.
Then differentiate it once
and multiply it by gamma.
Don't differentiate.
Take that equation and
multiply the omega 0 squared.
Add those 3 terms, you'll get 0.
I tried it last
night to make sure I
didn't write the
wrong thing here.
So that really works.
Again, if you want to know
how did I find this equation,
did I take it out of a hat,
like a rabbit out of a hat?
No.
You can look it up in books,
solutions of equations,
or actually Professor
Walter Lewin
did derive this solution also
using complex amplitudes.
And you can find
it in his lectures.
But from my point of view, I
don't care where I got it from.
That works.
So this must
describe the motion.
And it has 2 arbitrary
constants which
I can find out, because I
know the initial conditions
for this pendulum.
So once again, now I will try to
find the 2 arbitrary constants.
How did we do it before?
By taking our solution.
Well, we know that
theta of 0 is 0.
Therefore, if 0 is equal to A
e to the minus gamma over 2t,
that's t 0.
So that's 1 cosine
t 0, so I get phi.
So one boundary condition
tells me that phi is pi over 2.
Or there are others, minus
pi over 2 works, et cetera.
Doesn't matter.
Take any one of them and
providing you're consistent,
the other one will make up for
it to give you the same answer.
So anything that satisfies
this boundary condition
is fine for one of
those constants.
Now, the other one
tells me something
about the initial angular
velocity of the rod.
So I need to calculate the
angular velocity of this rod.
So here, I calculate
theta dot t at time t
by differentiating theta.
And I get this lower equation.
And now again,
theta dot at 0 time
is equal to-- we know
it is-- this number,
angular velocity at t equals 0.
So in this equation,
I plug that in.
I get that the
angular velocity at t
equals 0 will have to equal 2.
A, e to the minus gamma over 2t.
t is 0, so that's 1.
And 2 minus omega prime sine
of omega prime t, but t is 0.
So that's 0.
Phi, that's the sine of pi
over 2, because we find phi.
That's 1.
So I don't do
anything with that.
Minus gamma over 2 cosine
of omega prime t. t is 0,
so it's cosine of phi.
Phi is pi over 2, so that is 0.
So that's all right.
Therefore, A is
equal to now angular
velocity at t equals 0
divided by omega prime.
And therefore now,
let me move over here.
So now I can write
the full solution.
I have found
everything, and I find
that theta of t
from the second line
down is equal to
A, which we found,
angular velocity t equals
0 over omega prime minus--
there's a minus-- and now
it's cosine omega prime t
plus 90 degrees.
So that's the same as minus
sine of omega prime t.
The 2 minuses cancel,
so I get a plus.
And if earlier on you chose, for
example here, minus pi over 2,
then both of those signs
would have been plus,
and you still get
the same answer.
So it doesn't matter.
The algebra looks after itself.
So we have to found the solution
of this equation of motion
with these boundary
conditions for this situation
where the gamma and
the omega 0 squared
is such that this is
angle to correspond
to the low damping situation.
What kind of a motion is that?
If I plot this, again as we
do as a function of time,
if I had a room full of students
here who would correct me, then
I would have caught the mistake.
If you look at the
second equation,
it says take theta of t
is A e to the minus gamma
2t cosine omega prime t.
When I rewrote it plugging
in the value of A,
I forgot the e to the
minus gamma over 2t.
Sorry about that.
And we continue.
So now if I plot
this, what do I see?
If it wasn't for the e to
the minus gamma over 2t,
it would be a sine.
That's what it would look like.
t, and this is the
angle theta of t.
This would be the
simple harmonic motion
with no drag, no damping.
But this function is
multiplied by an exponential,
like this, which is dropping.
So the net result-- and
excuse my sloppy drawing--
is this modulated by that.
So it will be
something like this.
So what we get is damped
harmonic oscillation.
Now again, I can't
resist pointing out.
To me, it seems
almost miraculous.
You have the same equation in
form with the same boundary
conditions predicting
completely different behavior
if some of these constants are
bigger than the others or vice
versa.
So the mathematics has it built
in to that kind of solution.
Those two kinds of
solutions exist.
And that corresponds
exactly what
you would expect if you imagine
an oscillator with damping.
If you have this oscillator,
if it's highly damped, as I've
said before, you would expect
this crazy motion reaching
a maximum slowly coming down
and coming to a grinding halt.
Or if it's lightly
damped, you would
expect this to almost behave
like a normal harmonic
oscillator, but
slowly losing energy
due to damping and
oscillating with smaller
and smaller amplitude,
which is exactly
what the mathematics
said would happen.
I always like to ask
a crazy question,
how does the oscillator know
what the mathematical solution
is?
But somehow or other, it does.
It's a crazy way to phrase it,
but I always think of that.
So let's put together
actually what
we have seen in combination
of last time and this time,
my problem solving, my
attempts to teach you
how to solve problems.
What we found last
time was that we
took three different
harmonic oscillators.
One was a mass on a spring.
Another was this rod
oscillating like this.
The third was an electrical
system, an LC circuit.
In each case, we found that
we the equation of motion
looked exactly the same.
The only difference was what
was the name of the variable.
For example, in the
case of the spring,
the displacement from the
equilibrium was a distance.
So this equation was of this
form where the size was y.
When we came to this
oscillating rod,
the quantity which was displaced
from equilibrium was an angle.
So this sine was a theta.
In the case of the LC circuit,
the quantity was a charge.
So the charge which was
displaced from equilibrium.
But I could have summarized
the equations of motion
for the three
harmonic oscillators
by this one equation and
just tell you, well, this
is the equation
of motion for that
and put in the appropriate
quantity, which
is displaced and also put
in the appropriate value
of this constant, which for
the spring was k over n.
For the rod, 3g over 2l.
For the LC circuit is 1 over LC.
And believe me, we could
have taken a million harmonic
oscillator with no damping,
anyone you can think of,
and I could reduce
it to this form.
So here's something
new that we observe,
that you can take lots
of physical situation
but describe them in terms
of the same mathematical
equations.
The same mathematical
equation can
describe millions and
millions of different kinds
of harmonic oscillators.
So that is another feature
of the scientific method
that is very important.
It means now we don't
have to understand
every little thing that
happens in the universe.
We can reduce it to a smaller
subset of description.
Now, we've now add
the new feature today.
We added some loss mechanism.
We took a specific kind
where the resistive force
or the resist torque is
proportional to the velocity
of the analysis.
In our case, to the angular
velocity of the rod.
And we derived an
equation of motion,
which looks like this, where
these psis for the oscillator
we considered was the
angular displacement.
I don't have to be an Einstein--
by analogies to what I said
here-- to say look,
I could have taken
any one of the oscillators
in the universe.
And with damping,
if the damping is
proportional to the
velocity of the analogous
quantity of
velocity, I'll end up
with this equation of motion.
So this is the
equation of motion
of simple harmonic motion.
This is the equation of motion
of damped harmonic oscillators.
Every one of them.
But there is an interesting
difference we saw today.
There is only qualitatively
one kind of solution here.
In the case of the damped
harmonic oscillator,
there are two qualitatively
different solutions to that.
One is the sum of
exponentials and the other
is damped harmonic motion.
Both the quality of the
solution and the details,
whether it's oscillating
fast or slow, et cetera,
depends on those
quantities-- the gamma
and the omega 0 squared,
which in turn, for example,
in the various cases it's
k over n, 3g, et cetera.
So that will describe
all oscillators.
And in any particular
oscillator,
if you want to know what
exactly happens at the given
instant of time,
you then need also
to know those two constants,
the boundary condition.
If I have some mass on
the spring oscillating,
where it will be
at some later time
does depend where it is
at this very instant.
Finally, there's just one more
thing I would like to do today,
and it's the following.
Oscillators are not
only nice in order
to give you a lecture
on oscillators
or show you how to solve them,
they are practical devices.
So sometimes we want to know
some property of a given
oscillator.
Well, there are two
properties which
describe the quality
of a given oscillator
and what its behavior is.
One you've seen already is to
do the period or the frequency
of the oscillator.
In other words, you
could have one oscillator
which goes very slowly.
You're going to have one
which goes very fast.
I have an oscillator
and you want
to tell somebody what it's
like, a crucial number is what
its period is, the 1 over the
period which is the frequency.
Imagine, for example, a bell.
That's an oscillator.
You could have a bell which has
a low tone or a very small one
with a very high pitched tone.
So that's one number
that's important.
But there is another
number that's important.
Whether it's a good
or a bad oscillator.
And it's obvious what
is it good oscillator.
A good oscillator is one that
oscillates for a long time.
A bad one is that
doesn't continue
oscillating for
a very long time.
But again, you'd I'm
sure agree with me
that it isn't just how many
oscillations it does, say,
in a given time, like 1 second.
If I take an
oscillator that makes
one oscillation per second,
then if it survives 1 second,
you wouldn't say it's
a very good oscillator.
It barely made one turn, while
if the oscillator is making
a million oscillations
per second
and that survives
for a second, you
would say that's a
pretty good oscillator.
It made a million oscillations
before it ran out of steam.
So to quantify the quality of
an oscillator, we use a term,
and being very
imaginative we call
it the quality of the
oscillator, or Q value.
So I will finally
want to derive for you
for this particular oscillator
what is its Q or Q value.
And that's the last
thing I will do today.
Now, it only makes sense to talk
about the Q of an oscillator
if it's at least a
reasonably good oscillator.
This one, this overdamped
one who didn't even
make one complete cycle,
it doesn't make sense
to talk about its
Q. So the only case
where it makes sense to talk
about the Q of an oscillator
is if it makes at least
a few oscillations.
It's got to be the
underdamped case.
So I will now
calculate for you what
is the Q of this compound
pendulum, this rod which
oscillates on the conditions
where the drag force is small
so that it has this
undamped motion.
So let me do that.
The Q value of an
oscillator is defined
by no good reason of pi multiply
by the number of oscillations
the oscillator makes before its
amplitude drops by 1 over e.
It's a formal definition.
So take some oscillator,
which is a good oscillator.
So it oscillates like this.
It's decaying.
This has an
exponential form, as we
saw for a damped
harmonic oscillator.
And we ask the question
how many oscillations
it makes before the
amplitude drops by 1 over e.
And for historic
reason, 1 takes pi
multiply by the number of
oscillations for amplitude
to go down by amplitude over e.
1 over e.
Because the energy
stored in an oscillator
is proportional to
the amplitude squared,
this is equivalent to 2 pi
times the number of oscillations
it takes for the energy to
go to the energy over e.
These are equivalent because
1 is the square of the other.
And in fact, just
let me tell you.
I'm digressing here.
Originally this
was the definition.
The 2 pi is there because
in the definition,
one said what will be
the change of phase
of the oscillator for the
energy stored in the oscillator
to go down by 1 over e?
If you're talking about
the change of phase
rather than number
of oscillations,
you have 2 pi there,
because the phase
in one oscillation, the
phase changes by 2 pi.
So historically, this came in.
That's equivalent to this.
And so we have to
calculate that.
Now, for this
particular oscillator,
we actually calculated the
motion, how the angle changes
with time, and we see
that the amplitude drops
like e to the
minus gamma over 2.
So we saw that the
amplitude drops
like e to the minus
gamma over 2t.
So in what time will the
amplitude drop by 1 over e?
That time will be when gamma
t over 2 is equal to 1.
So you get e to the minus 1.
So it will be in a time
t equal to 2 over gamma.
Now, what we are
interested in is how many
oscillations will, in this
time, the oscillator make.
But you know the period T is
equal to 2 pi over omega prime.
I'm using here omega prime
because that is the angular
frequency of the
damped oscillator.
It was not omega 0,
like the undamped one.
And omega prime I
defined for you earlier.
But you know that if
the damping is weak,
omega prime is essentially
equal to omega 0.
Q is a quality thing.
We don't need it exactly.
So it's just to give you
a feel whether something
is good or bad oscillator.
So since omega prime is
essentially equal to omega 0,
I'll take the period
to be approximately
equal to this over omega 0.
So in time t, how many
periods will I have?
I have to divide
t by the period.
That'll be the number of
oscillations I'll make.
So it's 2 over gamma divided
by 2 pi over omega 0.
And so this is the
number of oscillations.
So the Q will be pi times
the number of oscillations
for the amplitude
to drop by this.
So the Q will be
equal to pi times
this quantity, which
is 2 over gamma divided
by 2 pi over omega 0, which is
equal to omega 0 over gamma.
So the quality of this
particular oscillator
will be equal to
omega 0 over gamma.
And I hope I still have it.
Do I have that?
Well, by going back
through this video,
omega 0 we defined
earlier on and gamma also.
And so you calculated this.
That's as much as
I was going to do
about damped
oscillations for you.
Thank you.